[موسيقى]
للارقام العدديه معنى ومغزى واهميه خاصه
عند العرب وغيرهم واكثر هذه الارقام
باستخداما هو الاربعين ليش لانه العدد
التكاملي لاطوار الحياه برمتها وهذا الرقم
يحمل في طياته العديد من العجائب والاسرار
ذات الاهميه البالغه عقائديا واجتماعيا
وحسابيا حتى اذا بلغ اشده وبلغ اربعين سنه
ومن امثال العرب يخلق من الشبه اربعين
والعام مهي يقولون بعد الاربعين الله يعين
انتبه لنفسك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وسن الاربعين محطه تحول مهمه للانسان من
الشباب الى ما بعده واهم مواسم العرب
اربعه منبعانيه الشتاء اربعين يوما موسم
العقارب اربعين يوما مربعانيه القيظ
اربعين يوما وكانت ثريا اربعين يوما
وواعدنا موسى ثلاثين ليله واتممناها بعشر
وسن الاربعين مثل الساعه ثلاثه لا هو تبع
صباح ولا تبع المساء قالت بلغت الاربعين
فهل ترى اني كبرت على الجمال فزال قلت
الذي سواك ابدع صانع زادتك تلك الاربعون
جمال كالبدر منتصف الزمان تمامه والان انت
اشد منه
كمال
[موسيقى]